salve a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti sia
questo nuovi d'oggi sia un sud del
rocket stop incidente non ho ben capito
che cos'è ma è figo quindi la soglia se
c'è un italiano per caso portoghese
pitching kn english l'italia non se le
cagate a nessuno ma tanto gli europei
l'abbiamo vinto noi quindi me la mettete
in gol
si parte raga non so bene effettivamente
di gioco si tratti però credo che sia di
stampo horror almeno che se non avrebbe
senso la mente solo il buongiorno
ok
sembra la scena di un film di
christopher nolan questa perché lascia
non si vede un cacchio mi sia un horror
reed ben for servers server o forza beh
è lavate le sue mani che già lo sporco
che ti cola dall'arma cose a noi un
laccio quello altro bellissimo tappeto
imperiale del sultano term sheet tu sia
il gusto 0 comunque svendere la parte
che ti serve la moneta dove abbado di
sopra posso vedere da qua
ok scusi c'è qualcuno qua no
c'è chi ormai la dorna torcia però
perché non si vede niente c'è veramente
non si vede una sega non si vede niente
a questa festa
io due o tre sedute dal chiropratico le
farei poi fate voi
wickens iu possiamo vederti anche io
vedo io
c'è il mio capitato di la adoro ragazzi
quando in un gioco c'è un altro gioco
sta cosa qua lavoravo già ai tempi di
gta san andreas non so se vi ricordate
che sarà casa di sigerico devi giocare a
delle robe bellissime comunque faccio
schifo per questo è un altro discorso se
il bagno anno non c'è il bagni st stanza
comunque attenzione sono i bagni in
comune distanza 103 ragazzi porta sempre
aperta quella 105 ragazze stava 103 non
vedo vado di qua maggio che sia questa
vc però non vedo aree krumm
stasera alle registrazioni allo studio
come me
ok
jo jo jo
vabbè oltre al 100 se non vengo acceso
che aumentiamo un po di grip pagine in
tutto questo resta la stanza 103 utility
un sabato utility
cosa ragazzi io non vedo non vedo
assolutamente niente già faccio fatica
ci manca socio un generatore non si
capisce cos'è se non vedo nulla gioco
buio buio accedete le luci dio ti
ringrazio posso sempre non era così
eliminato risolto comunque non so non so
se sono io ma con un'altra moneta cosa
prendo
a ventitre monete c'è un altro flop ido
tra le altre due monete che culo a ce
n'è un'altra eccola qua perfetto l'ho
trovata ne manca una sola può trovare
un'altra moneta raga eccola che culo che
culo schiacciato una cosa a caso
praticamente avente quale b 4 ott
c'è basta monete a led kalou che se
rimaneva in casa c'è anche una cassetta
che mi sembra giusto prezzo
ottenuto il disco e guardiamo la lazio
qualcun'altro scommetti a e invece no
strano
beh già l'icona non è male già l'icona
non è male inizializzazione
riallocazione procedura completata
quindi francesco non funziona porca
vacca vabbè peccato è questo rumore qua
tutto chiaro tutto ti abitua floppy disk
che vi teletrasportano mai visto l ho
schiacciato è la donna che il servizio
da cani sarà dal chiropratico lo zio c'è
una radio madonna che bello depetris no
ok siamo nel 1600 mi fa piacere madonna
che roba non c'è niente qua genere sono
i posti dove c'è il jump square però non
c'è stato il jam scritti anni fa no tipo
figli mia mi ammazzo veramente vi prego
di odio wind all altra finestra pleaser
sono nello del window c'è una cassa da
morto non funziona una sega departures
non si apre niente adesso diventato tipo
pt scommettete è tutto uguale in giro a
ecco perché lo scià jump square perché
rivela troppo ve lo dico io ragazzi lo
dico io
non mi fate in casa di odio window è
cambiata la posizione della della
campanella e tutto speculare cambiano la
posizione degli oggetti anche perché c'è
lo zio lo zio si guardando star trek
va bene io vado avanti comunque per
adesso è tutto tutto tranquillo io vado
alla tv non vedo non vedo criticità in
tutto questo lo sport e la musica che fa
schifo ma vabbè davanti
zio c'è il telefono vado al 6 risponde
la seconda è che poi in casino porca
[ __ ] si è staccato però andò e vabbè
non rispondono che torna indietro è
bello però a picchiarlo per me la sua
memoria questa società dove va bene
non fare per favore scritto da porca
dove vai è andato è andato di là
io vado di qui lo santo di dio
niente sempre più scuro ma dove vai
avanti
e blu no c'è un po di buio c'è lo zio
che si è mosso ragazzi quando non so poi
ma la vedo un po più griglia del solito
ok lo zio che si è mosso con attenzione
in certe letture st madonna diventa
sempre più buio e orribile frate morgia
tutta la merda via via via fogliare
palle fuori dalle palle di 6 staccato un
pezzo di joystiq vi si è staccato un
pezzo del joyce che non sono anche come
sia possibile questo cioè prima era in
the intero mi si è staccato un pezzo di
giuristi grazie comunque è stato bello
allegro ho ting jobs che era parte
comunque è stato non me l'aspettavo mai
se doveste sincero mi aspettavo tutto
tranne questo quindi sono studiato
apparecchio bene di sé e per spaventare
match e le nuove realtà perché non
giocate un po di ora non so se lo sapete
sono gli hana 1 quest'anno pokémon
spacchiamo tutto il giorno murati
era l'unica fonte di luce li avevo tra
l'altro sento articolazioni sento molte
articolazioni stato non vedo non vedo ma
sento articolazioni cosa tensor playing
cosa cosa che il nome linq to me ne vado
mi ha promesso da allora
[Musica]